the next issue though that I want to
talk about now is what is an
unmistakable uh undeniable error that
Hillary Clinton has made Hillary Clinton
is being criticized for recently telling
a room full of donors that about half of
all Donald Trump supporters are part of
the quote basket of deplorable 'he's
certainly creative use of language
although possibly a politically uh
erroneous statement let's look first at
exactly what Hillary Clinton said
grossly general istic you could put half
of Trump supporters into what I call the
basket of deplorable 'he's right
the race is sexist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic you name it but that other
basket of people are people feel the
government has let them down the economy
has left them down nobody cares about
them so Donald Trump's campaign
co-manager Kellyanne Conway reacted with
of course outrage is it real outrage or
fake I don't know but she posted to
Twitter over the weekend uh about these
comments uh that one day after promising
to be aspirational and uplifting Hillary
insults millions of Americans listen I
believe Hillary Clinton's comment was
completely unfair fifty percent of
Donald Trump supporters are not part of
the basket of deplorable it's more like
forty-five percent of Trump supporters
that are in the basket of deplorable the
rest are some combination of incompetent
or lacking mental capacity uh in all
seriousness this is a mistake
politically okay you go after your
opponent you don't go after their
supporters because ideally you want
their supporters to come and vote for
you now Hillary Clinton may feel that by
distinguishing between the fifty percent
that are in the basket of deplorable for
their racism and xenophobia and whatever
else uh and the fifty percent were just
frustrated with the system that she is
still going to be able to appeal to the
fifty percent that are frustrated with
the system I don't know about that I
believe this was undoubtedly a strategic
mistake you were sort of throwing in the
towel on fifty percent of Trump
supporters if you're indeed right that
they are in that basket of deplorable
but I want to propose to you something
else I don't think Hillary Clinton is
wrong about what she is saying longtime
friend of the show Greg Stevens who I
had the opportunity to to catch up with
on the phone recently laid it out this
way on his Facebook page and its really
really great and I put together a
graphic to basically explained to you
what Hillary Clinton is saying how many
people did Hillary Clinton insult well
let's go through the numbers her
statement was fifty percent of Trump
supporters are part of the basket of the
plural okay
2012 voter turnout was fifty seven point
five percent the Donald Trump national
support as of this morning September 12
2016 is forty two point nine percent and
Hillary Clinton's allegation is that
fifty percent of Trump supporters are
deplorable if we do basic math and say
well about fifty seven and a half
percent of the country votes and uh
forty two point nine percent of those
voters are expected to vote for Donald
Trump based on polling today and half of
them are supposedly deplorable we're
talking about twelve point thirty three
percent of the electorate this is barely
more than one out of ten voters that
hillary clinton claims are part of this
basket of deplorable based on their
racism and misogyny and xenophobia
pretty low I have to tell you I think
Hillary Clinton has underestimated these
numbers I don't think there is anything
inaccurate about what Hillary Clinton is
saying we all know if we have any
connection to the real world that one
out of 10 voters slightly more than one
out of ten voters are absolutely part of
that uninformed low-information
retrograde fringe be it for ray sisters
in a phobic or misogynistic views be it
for their completely retrograde uh
religious conservative views that have
absolutely no connection to reality I
think there is nothing wrong with the
math of what Hillary Clinton is saying
but it was definitely a political
mistake because it has made headlines
for days now Donald Trump gets an
opportunity to respond it's Trump who is
supposed to be making these mistakes and
everybody else capitalizing on it this
was a mistake for Hillary Clinton the
wording was not good but it's gonna be
real tough for you to find numbers that
prove to me that Hillary Clinton is even
remotely overestimating her case here if
anything she is under estimating it I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zipcar which gets you
a car when
you wanted when you need it they offer
all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids whatever
you need it includes insurance and it
includes gas you just pay for the time
that you actually use the car and you
can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com /
David support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at joined zipcar dot-com /
David